[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Never gotten
such an applause before.
I've done a lot of
things, but this
is the first time I feel like
I've done something worthwhile.
[APPLAUSE]
First of all, thank
you all for being here.
Shah Rukh and I were walking
when a bunch of Googlers
just did a flash dance, and
Shah Rukh joined in the back
as well.
So thank you all for
coming here today.
We are also live-streaming
this, so it's
being watched live in YouTube.
YouTube India is
live-streaming it,
as well as Google+
Hangouts On Air.
Shah Rukh needs no
introduction, but he's
one of the most popular and
acclaimed actors in India.
He has done a lot of things.
He's not just an actor.
He's a producer.
He's a philanthropist.
He has been given the Padma
Shri award by the government.
He has starred in over 50 films.
Started his career in
1992 with "Deewana."
Most of you probably
know this better than me.
And he has also won
the UNESCO award
for all his philanthropic
work as well.
They had a great
show last night.
A bunch of my
friends were there.
And Shah Rukh just told
me it was their last show
and so they partied
hard late last night.
So he's probably a bit tired,
but I'm very, very glad
he's here.
So let's welcome Shah
Rukh onto the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
SHAH RUKH KHAN: This is
overwhelming, first of all.
Thank you.
I love you, too.
So yeah.
That's it.
When I come to
America, it's the love
and the number of ladies
willing to marry me.
And what is surprising is
this time, I'm not saying no.
Especially everyone
here at Google.
SUNDAR PICHAI: I'm
worried, because my wife
went to your show last night.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: Is she back?
SUNDAR PICHAI: She's back.
SHAH RUKH KHAN:
Well, thank you very
much for having me over
here and all of you.
I'm sorry to keep
you waiting, but we
were kind of partying
until very late
because this was our
last show last night,
and we've done six shows
all across America.
And now, we head back and
go to London, do a show
and then back to the promotions
of our film, "Happy New Year."
But it's been
wonderful, and thank you
for having me over here.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Well,
thank you for coming.
I think a lot of people are
curious about what drew you
to acting, and how
did the journey start?
And for me particularly, one
of the things that struck me
is how much you
have a connection
with the common person in India.
The common man,
common woman in India
and the connection you
have all over the country.
So can you talk a
little bit about it?
SHAH RUKH KHAN: I never wanted
to be an actor, actually.
I was wanting to be either
a software engineer,
or-- No, really.
At that time, it was very new.
It wasn't as easily
spoken as now,
and so I did give my
entrance exam in the IT.
It seems like a joke, but I did.
I look stupid.
I'm not.
I'm really
intelligent, you know?
And just to let you
know, I did electronics.
I got 98, which is the
highest in India ever.
Those were the days
of diodes and triodes.
It wasn't with the
chips and things.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Anytime you want
to switch careers, let me know.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: I'd love to.
Yeah.
And then, I wanted
to be in sports.
I didn't want to act,
in film especially.
I kind of-- not
looked down upon it,
but never thought I'm cut
out for Indian cinema.
I did a bit of English theatre
with Mr. Barry John in Delhi.
I'm from Dehli.
And then, I hurt
myself-- my lower back.
And one thing led to the other.
There was a play
being done and I
know the people, all the
girls from Delhi Lady Shri Ram
College.
So there's a girls' college,
and they needed seven boys
to act with 85 girls.
And I got a job as a principal
dancer, not as an actor.
I had one line-- Annie Get
Your Gun, it's a famous play--
and I got a line in it,
which I said, "Annie, I
have a letter for you."
And it started like that.
And I continued with theatre.
Television became big in India.
Yeah, television started.
I went to get a house on rent.
Instead, I got a
rolling [INAUDIBLE].
Some years later, a year
later, it became very popular
and I got a phone call.
Somebody said, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm like no, this has
to be somebody else.
It's not a real call.
And they said, would
you like to do films?
And I said, no.
I'm not interested in films.
And then, something
sad happened.
My parents expired.
And I said, OK.
I want to stay in Delhi.
I was feeling sad.
So I went over to
Mumbai for a year.
I told my friends,
I'm back in one year.
I'm going to do five films,
get over the sadness.
And it's been 25 years.
I'm still not going back today.
I'm still here.
So my growth has been of someone
who has not really thought out
that I would be an actor.
It just happened.
One thing led to the other.
And I don't know if I'm
a good actor or not.
If I act well, if
I do well or not.
But I don't ever describe
the process too seriously.
I think it's very
boring for people
to hear how the art works.
I truly believe the art is much
more important than the artist.
And I'm very humble about
the fact there are so
many people like me, and
I'm very, very grateful.
So what I do is I
take things from life
and just continue acting,
have fun, smile a lot,
and share a lot.
I think acting is about giving.
I think somehow that's
made people like me
a little more than
the talent I have.
[APPLAUSE]
SUNDAR PICHAI: It explains
why so many people identify
with you, even in such a
diverse range of films.
What's the most challenging
role you've done?
Why?
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
SHAH RUKH KHAN: It's
always the next one.
Yeah.
It's never the one
that I've done.
Because if I've done it,
then it's over and done with.
However badly I
may have done it,
but it's no longer a challenge.
But I find the one
thing that I want
to do in cinema for
the last 25 years now,
because I've been
working and I don't
know how to extend and
give back to cinema--
Indian cinema, specifically.
So I want to make
it technologically
a little more
advanced than it is.
So what I like to
do is try and do
films with a lot of
visual effects in them.
I have a small department
of visual effects,
and I want to enhance
filmmaking in India
so that, technically,
we can be at par
with international cinema--
especially Hollywood.
And of course, we need
to make them shorter
and have less songs in them
for people to watch them.
OK.
So we'll keep them as
long and no songs in them.
More songs and longer films now.
But for me, the
toughest have been
films which I've
produced, actually.
Because people
didn't think these
are the firms that will work.
A film like "Ashoka."
I think a film
like [INAUDIBLE]--
and they all flopped miserably.
So let me tell you, they were
films nobody wanted to buy.
There was a film
called "Ra.One,"
which I made-- which I really
wanted to make so that I could
advance the
technological part of it
and a difficult film to make.
And now this one.
As an actor, I don't know.
No role is difficult,
because I don't
have a method that I follow.
I just take instances
from life, meet people.
And I meet so many people.
I love people.
I love the hugs.
I love to kiss them.
I love to talk to them.
Yeah.
We're doing the
kisses afterwards.
So I just get to know people.
And then somewhere
down the line,
whenever a role is given to
me, I kind of take from life
and use it.
And sometimes,
it's over the top.
Sometimes, people think
it's too simplistic.
But I think it reaches out to
everyone, touches everybody's
hearts, and people
identify with it.
So films like
"Chakde" were nice.
Swades.
There's [INAUDIBLE].
I like Don.
I find him very sexy.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Let's
talk a little bit
about the work you do
outside of movies, too.
There is Shah Rukh Inc,
which announced the whole KKR
and how we've done
there, and you've
been very successful with
Red Chillies as well.
So talk a little bit
about the KKR journey.
How did the IPL
journey all come about?
I know I've always
seen you in the video,
always there supporting the
team and they've done very well.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: And desperately
supporting the team.
Now, like I said, I
wanted to be a sportsman.
And this whole thing
started about leagues.
The three things I really
like-- I like entertainment,
I like children,
and I like sports.
These are three things
that really turn me on.
Nothing else, actually.
I'm not much of a sightseer.
I'm not much for travel.
I'm very boring.
I'm very, very boring.
The three things that I like,
is like watching films or video
games or watching
sports or children.
I love children.
So whenever there is a thing
that I can involve myself now,
because I've kind of
done well for myself
and I have a little extra money.
So whenever there's something
I get an opportunity to invest
in, any of these
things, I always
do without thinking of
the business aspect of it.
So business-wise, I don't know
if they're doing well or not.
My team is here.
They'll tell you.
I have to keep working hard
and bringing the money in.
But VFX was part
of entertainment.
IPL was, because I like sports
and I really wanted to play.
I wanted to be a football
player or a hockey player.
And it sounds very pompous.
When I couldn't
become a player, I
thought-- let me just go
ahead and buy a team instead.
But I did it for my kids.
SUNDAR PICHAI: That's
the way I think as well.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: Yeah.
Let's go buy a team.
My kids liked it.
We were sitting one
day and they said,
we should have a league
team because of the English
Premiership League and all.
And I just went and bought it.
And I remember we were to
bid for it the next morning
at 11 o'clock, and the
bidding was very high.
Much more than I could
afford or still can afford.
All the big carpets
were doing it.
I was awake, and I was
hoping somehow my bid was not
accepted, because I
didn't have the money.
So I just went ahead, and
after I bought it also,
we lost so many hours
and so pathetically
that it became very sad.
Business was bad, and the
game wasn't being won.
And it's been a
roller coaster ride,
but I stuck around with it for
three years now-- five years.
And some other things
I've done, because I truly
believe-- and some of
you are younger here
and you should
know this-- I don't
want to sound philosophical and
as if I'm giving you a lecture.
But just when you think
things are going to go wrong,
if you hold onto them,
they kind of turn around.
Just that last brink is
always the most important one.
SUNDAR PICHAI: You
mentioned education as well,
and I know you've
done work there.
What do you think about
where education is in India?
There's so many young
students coming through.
How do you think
technology can help?
This is what a lot
of us work on, so.
SHAH RUKH KHAN:
You know, I don't
think there's anything more
important than education.
And I'm very keen that my
kids are very educated.
And now, with technology
and this accessibility.
And you know,
education has become--
there used to be a time.
And still is, I'm sure, to
specifically specialize in XYZ.
You have to be a scientist,
you have to be a doctor,
you have to be an engineer,
and those things are important.
But I think the
overall development
happens when you can educate
yourself in a more round way.
And I think technology
can help there.
Just the fact--
I'll be very honest,
and I'm sure everybody
comes in and says that.
I'm not saying it
because I'm here.
But feel I don't need
a teacher or books
since Google has been there.
I find myself so
much more educated
in the last few years
because of Google.
I've got a yearning
for learning.
I really do.
And some of it, there's a
church next to my house which
says-- whatever answers
Google doesn't have, God has.
And it says that.
Every day, I pass it.
And I think it's one
of the nicest things,
and if you guys can extend just
beyond the search engine, which
my friend there is head of.
But just being able to give
people more access to more
subjects and topics-- and make
it fun, which you guys are.
That floor there
only [INAUDIBLE]
to step on those things, I
could spend the whole day there.
I would never enter
into the office.
But I think technology and
Google, specifically today,
can really help education
go far and wide to areas.
Especially in India, because the
internet is still not gone out.
There are areas where
schools can't be constructed.
And I think for India,
especially, it's very important
that the youngsters
are educated if you
want to change the country.
Because we have
everything going for us.
If we are just educated
a little more, or have
access to education.
So I would request everyone
who is working at Google,
figure out something specific.
Because you have the intelligent
ones, the smart ones,
and the fun ones.
Figure out some specific
things for Indian education
so that it reaches deep
inside the heartland of India,
because we need kids like
you coming here and ruling
the world.
SUNDAR PICHAI: We know you
have a new movie coming out.
It's not just Shah Rukh today.
We have two other
superstars to join us.
[APPLAUSE]
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Is
it just San Francisco?
Why are all the guys
only asking for me?
Even last night, remember?
SHAH RUKH KHAN: Yeah.
SUNDAR PICHAI: I was hoping
my name would come up.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN:
(SCREAMING) Sundar!
SUNDAR PICHAI: So they're here.
They're also doing
show-promoting the new movie.
It's called, "Happy New Year."
It's premiering for Diwali.
So maybe you guys
can talk a little bit
about the movie, what
the movie is about,
why you're excited
to be part of it?
SHAH RUKH KHAN: Let
me first introduce
Abhishek, who I've
known since childhood.
He's a wonderful, wonderful
co-actor, friend and one
of the most deranged and
fun person on the set.
Most distracted,
but most lively.
And the happiest, happiest
person that I work with.
So I thank him.
Deepika, as you all know,
started with [INAUDIBLE].
I like to show off and be
pompous and take the credit
for the fact that I made
her, which I can say openly.
And today,
unfortunately, she won't
be able to sing because
her voice is gone.
Otherwise, she would
have, normally.
She does a full [INAUDIBLE]
as soon as she comes, when she
[INAUDIBLE].
She does a whole [INAUDIBLE].
But she wouldn't
be able to do it.
The film is a heist film mixed
with a dance competition.
And easier to describe
it, though the stories
are not copied, though
people will say that.
But it's "Ocean's Eleven"
meets "Full Monty,"
if that combination
can ever, ever happen.
But Farah Khan
thought of the film
where, like a
regular heist film,
you have one guy-- a mastermind,
so to say-- who collects people
with different specialities.
Someone is a lock breaker.
Somebody's-- obviously, there's
one-- is it OK to say "nerd"
here?
SUNDAR PICHAI: Yeah.
I'm not one, but they all are.
SHAH RUKH KHAN:
Or I'll be pelted.
You have one
highly-sophisticated,
intelligent computer hacker.
And so on and so forth.
Abhishek has a
speciality which really,
really cannot be described,
because it's gross.
But you'll get to see it
when you see it in the film.
It's gross, the ability
that he has in the film.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN:
Special power.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: The
special powers that he has.
And I'll now defer-- I'll
request Deepika and Abhishek
to tell you a little
more about what they do.
Deepika, as you will hear now,
normally also sounds like this.
DEEPIKA PADUKONE: I didn't think
I had that effect on people.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: It's OK.
It was an Apple.
[LAUGHING]
DEEPIKA PADUKONE:
I'm really sorry.
I can't say much today
because I've lost my voice.
SUNDAR PICHAI: I think people
are just happy looking at you.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: We'll
do it in dumb charades.
We'll do it like-- three words.
Say, "How are you?"
How-- second word?
You.
How are you?
OK.
SUNDAR PICHAI:
Abhishek, do you want
to say a few words
about the movie?
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Know that
it's an absolute pleasure
to be here.
Contrary to what
everybody thinks,
we actually haven't
slept all night
because we've all been
so excited to come here.
Yeah.
But very honestly, just
to see all the Desis out
there is way cool.
I mean, I don't mean to sound
too much of a nationalist,
but it's just fantastic to see
that you guys are literally
running the world, man.
SUNDAR PICHAI: So we
do take questions,
which people have all submitted
both internally and externally.
And the most popular question
was throughout your career,
who has been your inspiration
for each of you, and why?
So if you could talk about that.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Yeah.
My eternal inspiration
has been-- so, yes.
For me, it's always been
my father in whatever I do.
Anything--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Yeah.
I love him, too.
And he's actually very
jealous that I'm here today.
He's more of a computer
geek than even me, so.
Actually, he must be blogging
right now as we speak.
So yes.
It's always been my father.
I think for not just his
professionalism, but just
the kind of human
being that he is.
His sense of morals and values.
Things that I've always admired,
and I aspire to be like him.
And whatever I do in life
is always for my parents.
And so I think my parents have
been my inspiration always.
DEEPIKA PADUKONE: Pass.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Pass.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: I
think even her dad
must be an inspiration for her.
Mr. Prakash Padukone, one of
the greatest, greatest sportsmen
the country's ever produced.
DEEPIKA PADUKONE: My
parents are my inspiration.
SUNDAR PICHAI: There you go.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: And who
is your speech coach?
DEEPIKA PADUKONE: You.
Since I started off with you.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: (MOCKINGLY,
WITH HOARSE VOICE) Oh yo yo yo.
Well, that's very sporting.
DEEPIKA PADUKONE: You
walked into that one.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: Yeah.
This was very good.
Can you do an
[INAUDIBLE] take-off?
DEEPIKA PADUKONE:
I-- Gee, sorry.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: I get inspired
by-- I've always said this,
and it may sound
a little strange,
but I get inspired
not by special people.
I get inspired by
ordinary people.
I find it's not special
to be a special.
It's very special
to be ordinary.
And I see people
who achieve so much
with such little
facilities at hand.
I get very inspired by that.
In terms of big people-- of
course, my parents died early,
but they were very
good teachers.
So some of the
people I've liked may
sound a little odd,
but Muhammad Ali.
I like the boxer.
I really get inspired
by his story.
I get inspired by the
story of Mother Theresa.
And I've never had
the opportunity
to meet either of them, but
whatever little I've read.
And I make it a point
to read about them,
and that's why
maybe sometimes, I
come across a little arrogant.
Because of Muhammad
Ali, not Mother Theresa.
But I like the way
he has led his life.
But more than that, I
think I just get inspired.
I find when I meet
people, I ask them--
how do you come
here for the shoot?
And they say, we
wake up at 5:00 AM.
We take a local train.
We've cooked food.
We've brought the
kids to school.
And now, we made it
here at 8 o'clock
and when we pack
up at 8:00, chances
are we don't make it back home
until 4:00 AM again, sometimes.
And I get really inspired
by ordinary people.
And that inspiration,
I take that.
I've gotten unfortunate now,
and I'm no longer ordinary.
And I should retain that
ordinariness around me
to be able to achieve
a little more.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Another
question which people
ask is about YouTube.
So how does the Bollywood
industry look at YouTube?
It's very popular in India.
What do you think about YouTube?
And there are many people
who work on YouTube here, so.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN:
Deepika will speak.
DEEPIKA PADUKONE: I'm
feeling so useless.
SUNDAR PICHAI: I know.
DEEPIKA PADUKONE: So sorry.
AUDIENCE: Keep smiling.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: I think
it's very, very cool.
I think it's really fantastic.
I get a little frazzled when I
have to put that over-18 thing.
That is a little confusing.
They have their little-- that
word that you have to type
what you can see.
With my eyesight, it's
really, really difficult.
It takes me five times to
tell them I'm 18 years old.
Please, next time if you find
me putting in those numbers.
No, I'm more than 18.
Allow me to watch everything
on YouTube, please.
I'm a busy actor.
I don't get to pick out the
films I really want to watch,
so I have to watch
them on YouTube.
But I think it's
really, really nice.
I spend my most fun
nights, actually,
when my kids are back home.
They're both grown up now.
They're 16 and 14.
My daughter and the little
one is still 16-17 months.
But our biggest source
of entertainment
is actually YouTube.
Because they find such
amazing stuff on there.
Such amazing-- more than movies,
and what are they called?
The youngsters call them epic
fails and the strange things,
the comic stuff.
Some people trying
to sing, dance.
As a matter of fact,
a lot of it-- a lot
of the dancing in the film when
we were doing "Happy New Year"
is about dancing from the
heart, not being a good dancer.
Celebrating the fact that
you don't know how to dance,
but you just go ahead and
dance, which 99% of people are.
We don't know how to dance.
We just are happy dancers.
And when Farah started making
the film, the first thing I did
is collected all
the weird dancing
from YouTube for inspiration.
Actually, we wanted to
start the film with that.
So it's really the most
entertaining part of the day
when my son and
daughter, they sit down.
And my son and his friends have
some strange, strange things
that they find on it,
which I didn't know.
Like some poker games and
poker champs, the lifestyles.
It's really amazing.
I think the most entertaining
time I have is on YouTube.
So thank you, YouTube,
for entertaining us.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Do you
guys use-- everyone
wants to know that you use
Google products, Google
technology?
Do you guys like them?
And any advice for people here?
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN:
Well, we didn't really
know where we were going
today, so I was on Google Maps.
Yeah.
And actually, Shah, before
we started the film.
Like you were saying,
as an inspiration,
we were all given this link to
this wonderful gentleman who's
made a video of himself,
who he basically
is an Indian villager who thinks
he's Spiderman or Superman.
So YouTube is something
that we all use.
And PewDiePie is
this one YouTuber
who gives a lot of
entertainment to all of us.
It's also nice as actors,
because previously, we
had to buy our own DVDs
to revise our work.
You see now, you
can just YouTube it.
So YouTube, Google
Maps are things.
and I was just told backstage
that I-- can I have the phone?
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is yours.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: This is mine.
So I think the greatest
thing is you all have almost
replaced everyday
things in our lives.
So there isn't any day
that you don't actually
go to work or just wake up
and not use a Google product.
So yes, thank you.
And we do use a
lot of your stuff.
Yes.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Very exciting.
I know they've
[INAUDIBLE] us well.
I think they have a trailer
for the upcoming movie.
So we want to play that so
you all can take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
--[SPEAKING HINDI] It was all
about a handful of diamonds.
[SPEAKING HINDI] Happy New Year.
-[SPEAKING HINDI]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SUNDAR PICHAI: I think we have
a few more of the cast members
here, so I'm going to
invite them onto the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello.
How are you?
Good to see you.
FARAH KHAN: Hello.
Who loves me?
SUNDAR PICHAI: We can hear from
Farah about the movie as well.
FARAH KHAN: I've never seen
so many cool kids together
in one room.
Thank you.
SUNDAR PICHAI: She'll
tell us a little bit
about the making of the movie.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN:
Do you have a mic?
SUNDAR PICHAI: Do you guys
want to share your thoughts
on the movie?
I've heard rumors
of an eight-pack.
An eight-pack is on the way.
FARAH KHAN: Do they not
want to ask anything?
SUNDAR PICHAI: Why don't
you share your thoughts
about the movie and
what led you to this?
FARAH KHAN: My thoughts,
right now, I'm damn nervous.
We are like, what?
25 days away from
the release and it's
literally like giving birth
to triplets all over again.
AUDIENCE: And it looks good.
[INAUDIBLE]
FARAH KHAN: I really
care about that.
Thank you.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING HINDI]
FARAH KHAN:
Eight-packs, but I don't
know if he's going
to show it to you.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN:
No, no, no, no, no.
Guys.
You see, this is
where you realize
she was talking about
Boman, not Shah Rukh.
FARAH KHAN: Boman doesn't
have an eight-pack,
he has a family pack.
MALE SPEAKER: Boman [INAUDIBLE]?
SHAH RUKH KHAN: No!
No!
SUNDAR PICHAI: [INAUDIBLE]
is one of my favorite movies
as well, so why don't
you talk a little bit
about "Happy New
Year," your role in it?
BOMAN IRANI: Well, I dare
talk about three idiots
on this stage.
But "Happy New Year,"
lucky to be cast.
In fact, I was the
first one cast.
FARAH KHAN: And let me
tell you, no casting couch
was used in this case.
BOMAN IRANI: Look,
I'd tell you it was,
but then, I don't kiss and tell.
That's another story.
But it was a privilege
to work on this film.
It was probably the greatest
time of my life as an actor.
And it's so wonderful touring
with these wonderful people--
Shah Rukh and
Abhishek and Deepika,
because it always
works out better for me
when the crowds are out there.
I send them out first so
they can distract the crowds,
and then I can make
my way out of it.
Farah Khan knows, so it's OK.
AUDIENCE: What is the best
movie of your past career?
[INAUDIBLE]?
FARAH KHAN: I think this is.
Shah Rukh?
Are you going to show?
SHAH RUKH KHAN: No, no.
I'm sorry.
I'm very, very shy
in personal life.
I really am.
They'll all tell you.
FARAH KHAN: Yeah, he is.
I personally trained him.
If you all see the
video we made of him
training to get his eight-pack.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: Yeah,
it's on YouTube.
We put it on YouTube.
Yeah.
FARAH KHAN: While
he was working out,
I was personally sitting
there and saying-- come on,
you can do it.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: But
I'm very, very shy.
OK, I'll try and show it.
I'll hide behind.
I'm sorry.
I'll stop blushing and all.
FARAH KHAN: Shah Rukh,
[AUDIENCE COMMOTION AND
APPLAUSE]
I don't know if it's a good or
bad thing, but more of the boys
were screaming.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: OK.
This is likely to go to that
over-18 section of YouTube,
then.
But I'll show it to you guys.
Before I leave, I'll show you.
I'll come personally,
you can touch it,
and then you can feel
it, and every girl
is allowed to name
every individual ab.
You can call it Chintoo,
Bintoo, Bulee, Pulee, whatever.
AUDIENCE: The show was
awesome last night.
Thank you.
FARAH KHAN: Thank you.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: Thank you.
FARAH KHAN: Best
crowd ever we had.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Yeah.
Really.
FARAH KHAN: Best crowd ever.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Me?
No, no, no.
BOMAN IRANI: Sorry?
FARAH KHAN: Abhishek, come on.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: What?
FARAH KHAN: She wants to
hear your [INAUDIBLE].
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: They
want to hear Boman sing.
FARAH KHAN: No, they
want to hear your rap.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: No, no.
They want to hear Boman.
AUDIENCE: (CHEERING) Abhishek!
SHAH RUKH KHAN:
We'll back you up.
We'll do back-up stuff.
SUNDAR PICHAI:
He'll back you up.
SHAH RUKH KHAN: And
Boman will do the--
SUNDAR PICHAI: He'll back you.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: OK.
SUNDAR PICHAI: And
if all else fails,
I'll back you guys up, too.
SHAH RUKH KHAN:
The groupie stuff.
FARAH KHAN: You want a mic?
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: No.
I'm mic'ed.
This is Google, man.
Relax.
So we can do--
SHAH RUKH KHAN: Boman,
stand behind him
so we can be the groupies.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: My boys.
My boys.
Come on.
FARAH KHAN: Do you need
Deepika to give the [? best? ?]
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Because her
voice is just-- so it says,
please wrap up in three minutes.
So here we go.
B-L-U to the double-F master.
Let's take it slow
girl, I'm a long laster.
Yeah, I'm a bad boy.
But I'm a good girl.
You have to say,
I'm a good girl.
BOMAN IRANI: I'm a good girl.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: You are.
You're a very good girl.
BOMAN IRANI: We're
not going to talk
about last night, Abhishek.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: But
you're still the girl.
BOMAN IRANI: I'm still the girl.
OK.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: OK.
So B-L-U to the double-F master.
Let's take it slow, girl.
I'm a long laster.
Yeah, I'm a bad boy.
BOMAN IRANI: But
I'm a good girl.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Out in the
club or on bed or on a rug.
BOMAN IRANI: I'm a good girl.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: My
rhymes are laid back,
so lay back while I
drop the playback.
Get to my group and then you'll
ask if you can stay back.
You're fine, so fine, I'm
going to keep you smiling.
Nice eyes, fine
fur, pimp styling.
BOMAN IRANI: And
I'm a good girl.
SUNDAR PICHAI: [INAUDIBLE]
right here, right now.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: Bomsie, sing.
Sing.
BOMAN IRANI: Careful
what [INAUDIBLE].
Please.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: We'll
back you up, Bomsie.
BOMAN IRANI: That's what
I was afraid of, actually.
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN: [HUMMING]
DEEPIKA PADUKONE: [INAUDIBLE].
ABHISHEK BACHCHAN:
Go for it, Bomsie.
Go for it.
BOMAN IRANI: Now,
don't go in this ear.
OK?
This one's damaged for life.
[SINGING IN HINDI]
Give me some sunshine.
Give me some rain.
Give me another chance, I
want to grow up once again.
FARAH KHAN: You could
have sung something
from "Happy New Year."
You know?
Just saying.
AUDIENCE: [COLLECTIVE YELLING]
SHAH RUKH KHAN: They're
busy dancing together.
SUNDAR PICHAI: While
this is a lot of fun,
we are holding about
2,000 people from lunch.
This is where Google
has lunch today.
So unfortunately,
we have to end this.
I'm the most unpopular
guy right now at Google.
But we thank all
of them for coming.
Thank you for everyone
on the live stream.
See you all later.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]